the brand new 2022 M2 iPad Pro belongs
in the trash last year I purchased
myself not one but two iPad Pros with
the M1 chip I bought one for myself as a
professional architect and one of my
wife now I decided to buy the M1 iPad
instead of any other iPad ever released
for the very simple reason that it was
the best upgrade and best release Apple
has ever produced since the original
iPad ever came out the processor was
perfected the pencil was perfected and
the keyboard was incredible so naturally
you would think the next version of the
iPad Pro the M2 iPad Pro would be an
even better beast of a machine well no
just straight up no today I'm going to
break down exactly why as an architect I
will not be upgrading the M1 iPad to the
M2 iPad and why you as any other design
professional shouldn't do so either so
what's actually changed well we've moved
from the M1 chip to the M2 which means
we've increased 18 now CPU performance
35 percent GPU performance and 40 in the
neutral core overall what does that mean
for any lay person or any architect
design professional in the industry
absolutely nothing the M1 iPad is so
powerful that you don't actually need
much more of a boost and this minuscule
update of 18 or 35 percent doesn't
justify a huge new release and I think
Apple knows this they've produced a very
low budget Zoom call basically to
announce this brand new iPad and
released a video on YouTube the CEO Tim
Cook didn't even say one word about it
so basically even in Apple's eyes this
release is basically being brushed under
the carpet nobody cares about it if you
buy a new one great if you don't they
don't care the new M2 iPad has the same
storage the same Ram the same memory the
same ports same cellular connectivity it
has the same screens same as pixels per
inch same maximum display brightness
same P3 color same battery life same
weight and demand mentions you see we're
getting onto a very similar Trend here
and the best part about it all I guess
is its costs exactly the same price as
the last iPad Pro so what actually is
different why would anybody go out and
purchase an M2 iPad instead of an M1
iPad that they may already own well
instead of getting the basic plastic
USBC Cable in the box that we're so
accustomed to you're going to be
showered with gifts you're going to get
the brand new braided USBC cable like it
is the best gift Apple could ever give
you you're also going to get the words
engraved on the back of the iPad stating
iPad Pro not just iPad like every other
predecessor before it and what's even
better that space gray color we all love
so much that's darker on the new iPhone
14 and a beautiful color on the M1 has
actually gotten lighter on the M2 iPad
for no particular reason there are some
minor technical upgrades as well you now
get Wi-Fi 6E instead of Wi-Fi 6
providing better connectivity you get
Bluetooth 5.3 instead of Bluetooth 5.0
you also get the ability to use the pro
cameras on the iPad as an actual film
camera now you can do 4K 30 frames a
second prores video so I don't know how
many people are actually using an iPad
to record prores video but I certainly
am not you can also now capture HDR for
photos from the iPad which basically
means everybody's grandma is going to be
able to take even better high definition
photos of them but everybody else in the
world isn't even going to activate the
camera app on their iPad if you're an
architect like me and use the apple
pencil almost daily and religiously
there is a new upgraded feature for the
M2 iPad it's basically a 3D
electromagnetic sensor that's connected
to the tip of the pencil and registered
from the screen now what does this do
well it basically just tells your iPad
whether the pencils hovering above it so
we can give you a little bit more data
and a little bit more accuracy how much
of an added benefit is this well it's
still magnetically clicks the side of
your iPad and does everything it used to
do before except the iPad just knows
where it kind of hovers above the screen
personally I don't think it is that big
of a deal and I don't think it is worth
the upgrade at all now clearly I've
given you a very negative very one-sided
biased opinion which is my personal
opinion because I already own an M1 iPad
I don't see the need to upgrade to the
M2 from the M1 anyway shape or form
however if you have an iPad that is a
decade old if you have an iPad that's
dying the battery doesn't last the
screen's cracked any reason whatsoever
that isn't a good condition M1 iPad or
even the M1 iPad Airs then you should
probably consider upgrading to the M2
because the M2 over any bionic chip from
the a series is 5 are better it is a
superior product it is something that
can handle almost any design task and
truly make your workflow as a
professional so much better anyway
that's all for me today guys thank you
so much for watching I hope you enjoyed
the video if you did there's more videos
in this playlist to the side of me if
you love the video make sure you smash
that subscribe button down below leave a
like and a comment if you'd like to ask
me anything and like always I'll see you
next Monday